what Mark said was it's utterly
impossible to measure the changes of
things by time quite the contrary time
is an abstraction at which we arrive
from the changes of things
and also in Mach it was from Mark I
learned the insistence he had on the
relativity of motion or position that
you define position relative to other
objects and really ever since then I've
been thinking my question has been what
is time what is motion uh and and I'm
still working on that and I've got a
wonderful group of collaborators now
some are in their early twenties uh then
I've got some in their 40s and another
very good mathematician who's about 60 I
guess so it's it's actually speeding up
now these these things let me make one
comment though about Einstein if I may
well Ernst Mark died in 1916
Einstein wrote A very handsome obituary
of him
and among other things he's he quoted
that passage about time that I've just
given and described it as a gem
but if you look through all of his Works
everything he did and what he wrote I
don't think you'll find any attempt by
Einstein to put that into reality in his
work
and what he when he was asked what is
time I think his answer was very much
like what Frank wilcheck said it's what
a clock tells
but he didn't but then which I think is
very significant
in his autobiographical notes in 1948 he
said when he'd created general
relativity he'd committed a sin
in that he'd introduced two quite
distinct things one was the space-time
manifold with the metric on it and then
completely independently he admitted
that he was bringing in from outside
rods and clocks that measured it and he
said that's inconsistent the rods and
the clocks should emerge out of the
fundamental equations of the theory
and and he never did that but in fact I
think one of the things in chapter seven
of my book I do explain how at least
within Einstein's theory rods and clocks
do emerge and that indicates strongly
that they don't exist near the Big Bang
so I think we have to rethink very
radically
how we think about the conditions at the
Big Bang because there aren't any rods
and clocks there